[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kisses
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic expert guests this week is
the former deputy mayor of London for
education and culture who now works in
the arts we know Rosa
welcome to trigonometry hi thank you
[Music]
it's so good to have you here thank you
so much for coming on we met at the
Battle of ideas and we'll get into
talking about some of the stuff you were
talking there but before we get into the
show itself tell us a little bit about
who you are how are you where you are
what's been your story through life and
how there's maybe something that's
influenced the beliefs and views you now
have tell us a little bit about that as
well
okay well first of all thanks for having
me on I grew up in a town called Oldham
in the northwest of England
splendid area and very nice area and my
parents are immigrants from Pakistan or
they they came over from Pakistan and I
guess it was a you know fairly ordinary
upbringing I went to a comprehensive
school and in many ways you know my
family is an immigrant success story we
went to university I was very lucky I
got to ask fir'd I was quite an academic
student and I think when I was at Oxford
and then since I became interested in
politics I met people from different
backgrounds left and right and I became
particularly interested in the
relationship between culture and
politics and I studied English
literature I was interested in the arts
and I've always I suppose been curious
about how culture defines us and
reflects our values what we think of
society what it means to be human and
conversely how our values and ideas
shape the arts and shape the culture
that we produce so I've always been
interested in how our identities are
shaped by the culture around us in terms
of my politics I suppose I started off I
call myself left-wing although over the
years I found
my arguments with people tend to be
stronger with people on the left and
maybe that's because the world has
changed a great deal
but I've I guess I've always been
suspicious of consensus and norms and
wanted to question what I see is
orthodoxies around certain things and in
my 20s I became particularly interested
in the discussions around
multiculturalism and quite early on in
the 2000s I started writing critically
about multiculturalism but before it was
really I think being debated a lot I you
know I wrote a series of essays and
articles challenging what I thought was
in some ways a kind of ideology that was
meant to be about equity and fairness
and liberating people from oppression
and what has become I think quite a
rigid and oppressive ideology in many
ways which has tended to box people into
categories and I've always been worried
and maybe I am partly influenced by my
own background I'm you know I'm from an
ethnic minority background but I've
never felt that I am just defined by
that but I think that increasingly we
tend to think of people as being defined
by these characteristics and almost
assuming that some of them are good
inherently good and some of them are
inherently bad and we tend to make
judgments which are prejudicial and not
not really fair not really seeing people
as individuals and to me whatever was
progressive and positive about
multiculturalism a large part of that
has evolved into something which I think
is holding people back and and I've
always thought that that was very
counterproductive for ethnic minorities
it's not a you know it's not a popular
mainstream view I think more I think
more and more people are challenging it
but and you know we can talk about that
I know now quite a lot of ethnic
minority people who sympathize and you
agree that something that was meant to
be in their interest is actually
starting to work against them and
working against you know proper
relationships and society really
harmonious relationships is becoming
quite divisive well a lot of our viewers
actually when we went to the Battle of
ideas where we may as I said there were
loads of people coming up to us
and I'll be honest with you deep down
inside I was like I wasn't expecting you
to be from this background you know even
though it makes perfect sense people
from different backgrounds they don't
have a monolithic way of thinking but
you talk about multiculturalism and it's
interesting that we actually don't talk
about anymore it's almost like we've
kind of accepted that the merkel and
david cameron both came out and said
that it's not working and kind of we've
moved on to something else which is
identity politics know it's kind of
morphed into this thing isn't it yeah
essentially I see them as similar things
they're different words for a similar
trend so even if the language has
changed because the language is stop
being fashionable or you know
politicians like Cameron and Merkel have
recognized that there's a kind of ground
soil against some of these ideas they
still continue their petrol acid but
they come in different words and
different languages so you've now got
concepts like white privilege and you
know identity politics and protected
characteristics and this is the new the
evolution of the same the same kind of
approach and I'm always clear when I
talk about multiculturalism I'm not
against a multi-ethnic society when we
live in a multi-ethnic society there are
people with differences I come from a
background which is obviously ethnically
different to the mainstream majority in
this country and I don't want to live in
a society where there is intolerance I
want to be somewhere where we recognize
that people have differences and and
that's part of what it is to live in a
kind of cosmopolitan place particularly
someone like London where I live now but
I think the idea that our differences
define us that they should be things
that determine policy that we should
treat people differently because of
those cultural differences I think that
can lead us into all sorts of dead ends
and it can be quite device if it ends up
I think making something which knows a
fact in society we are different but it
makes it much more rigid makes it much
more difficult for people to transcend
those identities you know I I am an
Asian woman from the north I have a
working-class background but there are
lots of things about me which cannot be
contained by that you know different and
I and I suppose again you know going
back to my own back
I never thought when I was growing up
that I only wanted to read read writers
who were Asian women from working class
backgrounds yeah
the things like there are great writers
here you know oh you know I I sort of
subscribed to the the the sort of famous
line by the Roman playwright Terence
nothing human is alien to me and I think
the idea that you know we are human we
can empathize with each other through
culture through the arts that that's one
of the great things about the arts and
even the things that I'm drawn to when
you read a book you're seeing the world
through somebody else's eyes and the
ability to transcend that universal
impulse I think is a very powerful one
and we've become I think as a society in
the arts and in academia we've come
quite skeptical about the idea that
there is such thing as great are that
everyone can enjoy and real and relate
to its that's seen as you know the sort
of thing that they would have said in
the past very old-fashioned notion
that's for dead white men yeah and
really what we need now is to teach
young ethnic minority people about their
culture they need to see themselves
reflected in the art that's in the
galleries or in the books that they read
in school and I just think it's very
limiting and I I'm sure that I'm not the
only person who feels that way you speak
to artists actually and they're
sometimes the most worried about this
kind of categorizing you know the way
that often funding works in the arts you
know scenar that there's a sort of
designer you've got to we've got to have
more be any people in the arts but then
that becomes quite limiting because you
end up getting black artists and saying
well we're giving money out for people
who are creating art that's that you
know that's about diversity and that's a
norm you know where artists first and
foremost and the kinds of subjects we're
interested in might be science they
might be you know climate change might
be anything and why do you assume that
the thing I'm obsessed about is my
identity but but we do that all the time
we perpetuate that and do you think it
is as a trend it's getting worse and
because to me and I mean I used to be a
drama teacher I'm in comedy it seems to
me that we're progressing evermore down
this path or it seems to be oh you know
where this person is getting this
opportunity not because of the art where
they create but because they go oh
because they are x y&z blah blah
therefore they are here and you just
think but surely we should just be
judging the art ultimately isn't where
the artist is from irrelevant because
when you go and look at a Michelangelo
you it doesn't really matter that white
man that way man dead white gay man so
you know the gay doesn't count anymore
man okay fair enough
[Laughter]
it doesn't matter who the artist is what
matters is the art short well yeah yeah
I mean I think what would say for a lot
of artists their identity is part might
be part of the art they may and that's
perfectly fine yeah it's hard to imagine
someone like you know Benjamin Zephaniah
you know his his background his cultural
background his experience as a part of
the the poetry that he writes and that's
fine but I think at the end of the day
when you were you know when you're
making judgments you're judging the
quality of that work and how well he
communicates that experience and there's
something about that which is more than
just he takes a box and his patrin izing
to someone like him to say well the
reason that he's considered a you know
great poet and you know significant is
because he takes the box it's because
he's telling us something about the
human experience and he's he's bringing
a different perspective so I think
you're right that we we've forgotten in
a way that the artists the individual
artist is bringing all their personal
experience to bear and that that can be
very wide-ranging it's not just about
their ethnic experience although that
might be part of it is it's lots of
things and in fact the one thing we
don't talk about in the arts as much in
terms of diversity is political
diversity and certainly caste diversity
is an issue although that's more of a
conversation now but but people do bring
different perspectives and we shouldn't
sort of pretend that we're all atomized
individuals that don't have shared
experiences or shared cultural
identities it's just if we're if we're
starting to judge that as more important
than other things then then we get into
trouble I probably I don't know if I've
explained that well enough yes I'm
trying not to say culture is irrelevant
ethnicity is irrelevant because I think
it matters to a lot of people we're just
going to clip that
[Laughter]
no I know exactly what you're saying I
think that the thing between the TV is
basically you're saying culture and
ethnicity can be important but what he's
saying is that shouldn't be the basis in
which we evaluate exactly
you should be advanced promoted
attention yeah and you know sometimes it
you know sometimes it can be as crude as
that you know you and I you know won't
name names but I've been involved in
meetings and conversations and
organizations well you know we need to
increase the the proportion we need to
increase a target and they're responding
to a very real pressure because they're
you know there are that many by
comparison ethnic minorities in the art
sector or in parts of academia or in the
media and publishing and there are there
are reasons for that there are
long-standing reasons I don't think it's
about racism as it happens in the way
that is commonly described I think there
is a reason why you know people from
poorer backgrounds tend to not go into
insecure employment in the cultural
sector you know there's you know these
are not us you know jobs that you know a
lot of families will aspire for their
children to go into because they would
worry about you know so so we could talk
about low pay in the arts or in
publishing let's talk about you know you
have the deprived comedians yes but you
know it's have a meaningful conversation
we have to get away from this idea that
they're not getting in because they're
black and therefore we have to correct
that well let's talk about this because
I think one of the most impressive
interviews I've ever seen online of you
and has very few views actually I
noticed so go and watch this interview
that I'm about to talk about is you
talking to the BBC about the
government's race order where
essentially what they found was that
certain ethnic minorities were not very
doing very well in certain areas
incidentally one of the things they
didn't really raise is that certain
ethnic minorities are doing incredibly
well in certain areas and for example
white working-class boys are doing
incredibly badly you know in fact in
education right but anyway they were
they were asking you what you thought
about this and and it was all kind of
served with this
source of racism and discrimination any
disparity tasting source yeah yeah but
you've got to be careful Francis has got
a really racist sounding voice so and
you were kind of trying to explain to
them this very simple concept which is
that not all disparities and outcome
reference actual discrimination or
racism so let's talk a little bit about
that can you tell us for anyone who
wasn't aware of it what that race what
it was and what kind of what you think
about it yeah the government announced
or Theresa May announced when she became
prime minister that she was going to
tackle burning in justices in society
and one of the announcement she made was
that the government would run something
called racial disparities order so it
would look at how different ethnic
groups fare in British society in the
public services so the NHS and health
and education but also Nair is about
employment and other kinds of
discrimination policing criminal justice
system and so on and the report was
published last year or the website was
launched that showed these statistics
and interestingly the the audit revealed
that the pic that was very complex it's
it's not clear-cut that white people
always do better and I think minorities
always do worse in fact there is some
areas where I think minorities are doing
really well so if you look at the NHS
for instance about a third of doctors in
the NHS or BM e the non white or third
of seniors also than the NHS are
normalize so there are some areas where
actually there's a real success story or
something celebrate but when the audit
was published all the emphasis from
government and from the media was on the
negatives where the amorites are not
doing well and it perpetuates what I
thought was a very negative inaccurate
picture really of British society you
know it reinforces this idea that I
think minorities are being
systematically oppressed that there's a
kind of institutional problem when in
fact what we've seen in the last 20
years is the kind of liberalisation
and opening up for many people and my
worry has always been that when you tell
that negative story it both you know it
skewers policy it means that people make
bad policy decisions because they think
they're trying to correct something
that's actually working quite well
but it also reinforces for a lot of
younger people this idea that they can't
succeed and that I think can have quite
a big material impact it can mean that
they're not motivated to go out apply to
university go and be ambitious seek good
jobs because they'll think that they've
always got a kind of white racist
decision-maker who's holding them back
and I think that can create a lot of
tension and division in this society if
you're constantly telling people from
ethnic backgrounds that the business
ices against you that's not going to be
great for engineering harmonious social
relations you know they're going to be
resentful have you've made the point
even further actually that for example a
black defendant who's suspicious about
his lawyer is more likely to make a bad
decision for example to plead innocent
when in fact they should plead guilty
and as a result of that you end up with
young black men getting harsher
sentences yeah because they don't trust
the system and they don't do that what
they ought to do kind of in a percentage
place situation yeah the criminal
justice system report which was also by
or led by David Lammy MP showed that
there was this disparity I mean in many
other areas many of the parts the
criminal justice system the the
disparity between ethnic groups can be
explained by a number of different
factors the fact that there are you know
proportionally a higher number of black
men in in the criminal justice system is
is you know there are reasons for that
you know there are higher proportions of
arrests you know the you know you can go
into the detail of that there was one
disparity which was interesting in that
report which is why is it that black men
are more likely to receive harsh
sentencing and they found interestingly
as you say that that they were not
pleading guilty because they didn't
trust the advice of their solicitors and
they didn't trust the system
and that's a I thought I would argue is
partly result of not completely but it's
partly result of their fear that the
system is going to be prejudiced against
them so it has this really
counterproductive effect it's you know
damaging to their life chances really
and the same things happened in other
areas like mental health for instance
where we know that there's been a huge
amount of debate and discussion about
whether the institutional there's
institutional racism in the mental
health system because a higher
proportion of ethnic minorities are
likely to appear in the system and to be
detained to forcibly detained
she's obviously worrying when you look
at the statistics I mean why is it you
know they more likely to have mental
illness yes they are actually you know
there's lots of good research to show
that there for all sorts of reasons they
have higher risk factors but also what
they what researchers have found is that
a lot of people from ethnic groups are
worried about how the system is going to
treat them so they don't report until
it's almost too late until they're their
condition has worsened to a point where
they may end up being violent to
themselves or other people and at that
point they need to be forcibly detained
at that point the police get involved
and you have a very different the system
has to react differently to you so
matheno straights me is that people use
these statistics almost with the
political agenda to try and prove a
point about systemic racism but the
effects of that is even more damaging
and if we were more honest if we were
looking the statistics more
dispassionately you would see that it's
just a really complex picture and and I
think ethnic minorities are you know the
ones who suffer the most often you know
because no one's really thinking about
their interests as you know as
individuals in the system they're just
thinking how can we make a political
point how can we show that we're
virtuous you know I think in the in the
case of a government I think the
government was trying very hard to show
that it wasn't the nasty party anymore
that you know they care about these
vulnerable groups but in doing that they
you know they have perpetuated a lot of
these perceptions and this very negative
story you say something really loud
Tamar's gonna say
helicopter we keep telling you to
Kannamma tree that no one wants us to be
having these comments there's a [ __ ]
helicopter hovering above us in there by
the way we forgot to explain in the
beginning of the interview that we're on
location as we told you last week and
we're one of our big fans it's equally
true just above yeah there's a
helicopter hovering above us just
recording everything and reporting us to
the police for a hate crime yeah yeah
we're gonna be was gonna have to make a
run for it and as me as the white man
I'm gonna give up scot-free
[Laughter]
[Music]
typical exactly but there's one thing
that we didn't cover when we look at
these snaps and I as a former teacher I
do find it incredibly interesting is
work and white working-class boys all
we're always at the bottom when it comes
to stats and I sometimes think that if
it had been you know working cause black
boys working for us agent boys there
would be a massive outcry about it
rightly so but because it's
working-class white boys we tend to
stick struggle show doesn't go oh well
what can you do let's crack on and they
do tend to be forgotten almost yeah I
think I think that has changed actually
I mean in the last few years there's
been more awareness of the fact that
it's not just it's not it's not just a
racial thing yeah and and what we don't
want to get into is this idea that
somehow white working-class boys are
being failed because of their whiteness
either you know there are problems with
our education system actually I think
what's happening is that a lot of
immigrant families are correcting and
are intervening and are you know getting
their kids to go to private tutors to
correct for faults in the system and you
know it's not unusual if you're going
you know if you're driving around South
London you will see in shop windows
adverts for maths and English tuition
for immigrant groups you know there are
Saturday schools there's a very strong
culture of supplementary schools in the
afro-caribbean community for instance
these are all to try and correct for
what they perceive to be problems in the
education system and that hasn't been
the case for a lot of white
working-class communities but yeah you
know we have to I think we should focus
our education
Demond you know supporting the people
who are struggling whatever their ethnic
background and so for too long we've
racialized a lot of these problems
this is the pointman areas like what
Francis questions reveals under your
answer is that we we think in terms of
race all the time now and this way of
thinking encourages white people to
think about well well if you're talking
about these ethnic minorities what about
us we're victimizing this area I mean
it's just like and even if you don't
agree with it as I don't I was driving
home the other day and there was a girl
waiting to cross the road and it was
like one of those choice situations I
could have driven I could have let her
pass and I swear to God I looked her and
she was black and I went oh she's black
I got a letter through you know this is
how we start to think and it's crazy
isn't it this is absolutely mental that
we've been encouraged to think in this
way I'm for not being racist even
laughing about it yeah I think people
change their behavior and they're on
guard the sensitivity about it and you
know the the the the end result is that
you end up treating people differently
because their race and they know it so I
remember I think I may have said it even
at the battle by deer session that was
that that there was one writer I won't
name as she wrote a blog he complained
that white people would come up to her
and say how articulate she was and she
felt that this was an insult because
really they weren't expecting her to be
articulate because she's a black female
and I thought you know even when when
compliments are treated as some kind of
you know expression of racism you know
where there's literally nothing you can
do everything you say and it could be
that they just thought she genuinely was
articulate and they were congratulating
her for it but people then become very
defensive and afraid I remember reading
a report a long time ago it was a I
think it was in the it was a report of
the Met Police almost over about ten
years ago and they noted that but black
police officers were more likely to be
formally disciplined than white police
officers and the Met and there was a
discussion in the paper about you know
what was the driver behind this
and it turns out one of the reasons is
because their superiors were so worried
about having informal conversations with
them about problems that they felt they
had to go through the formal means and
that's what happens we don't trust our
instincts we don't trust how people will
perceive that we don't think that they
will give us the benefit of the doubt so
we do everything in a much more formally
formally regulated way so in the
workplace people are afraid of
interacting with their colleagues in a
particular way you know the word said
incorrectly or a slightly insensitive
remark you know where do you come from
that kind of thing is now regarded as
racism could get you discipline you
could end up in a racial grievance
situation you know the workplace is a
you know essentially it's still a
workplace you know you have a boss they
have the power to sack you so the kind
of informal social relationships that
you need to be healthy in order for a
civic society to be strong or being
weakened by you know people's you know
kind of desperation to jump on so
anything as being potentially offensive
and and often people self-censor which
you know it's terrible you can't you
can't have more human contact with
people you know proper social
interaction if you're constantly
worrying that they're gonna be upset by
what you say you made the great point
just one final thing miss Frances you
told the story about your dad's
colleague mmm to tell us that because I
thought it was such a great story about
the power of interpreting things in
different ways yeah do you interpret
something as in the fence what do you
interpret something as as a you know as
a way to connect to connect my dad
worked in a car parts factory for about
20 years of his at the end of his
working life and a lot of his colleagues
were white working-class older Murs and
every year one of them calls home would
ring up on Christmas Day and wish you
know wish him and the family happy
Christmas he knew that we were a Muslim
family but he rang up because it was the
nice thing to do you know you wanted to
make an effort and and even when my my
dad passed away he would ring up you
know in the years that followed and just
just to say that and it the way that I
interpreted it was a very kind gesture
and he wanted my dad to feel welcome you
know we were
Asian family in Oldham and it to me you
know it felt like a kind thing to do
very human thing to do but is now you
know you think about it and you listen
to so-called anti-racist talking about
white privilege and they would say well
you know it was a bit insensitive to
ring up a Muslim family and wish them
happy Christmas and you can imagine the
comment like that would be regarded as
insensitive rather than you know a
humane and kind thing to do and that's
the sort of madness that we're in the
the people's intentions are
misinterpreted willfully misinterpreted
often and I think that something is
going on in anti racism today where I
think there is a are kind of as well as
a political agenda I think there's a
sort of you know really kind of almost
corrupt tendency among some people to
see a problem to see a system in a
negative lie because it gives them
something to have a grievance about and
there is a currency to victim culture
not saying that people aren't victims
you know you can be a victim of racism
in this country today and I personally
experienced racism it's not a nice thing
I think imbalance I've been fortunate
enough that the vast majority of my
interactions with white people have not
been racism you know you know the casual
races here on my life joking aside is a
serious thing it's a horrible course and
you know I I'm I found her personal
experience of that so so do I look
looking the way I look in Russia and
actually in this country as well you
know but the question always for me my
my parents were always very clear with
me that those are just stupid people
they're not representative of a group of
people or of society someone being
racist to you isn't representative of
that group of people just in the same
way that you are not representative of
the group of people that you come from
you're just an individual yeah and and I
think something has changed in the last
sort of thirty years when I was growing
up there was more racism even even then
it wasn't as you know as dramatic as it
was
20 years before that you know Britain
was a more racist society in the 50s and
60s and you would see people being much
more offensive but I think the
difference was that it was a is a
broader social phenomenon and it was
more acceptable and you could get away
with saying things which were deeply
offensive and you know there were people
in senior positions of authority who
could say things but something changed
in the 70s and 80s and some of that has
to do with anti racism campaigning and
people on the left and progressives as
well and and you know the lot of credit
should be given to them but also there
was a liberalisation more generally in
society in the workplace and I think the
ironically the sort of the the changing
workplace relations with regards to
unionization meant that a lot of those
jobs that would have been in a more kind
of closed way past you know from father
to son or communities those opened up so
more ethic Morrissey's had the chance of
getting those jobs I think the kinds of
industries and jobs that have opened up
in the last 20 years in areas like law
finance accountancy they are more open
and porous so you don't have to have
known someone in that family to go and
get a job in a in a bank if you think
about some of the bigger industries like
the printing industry around Fleet
Street
they were very white male-dominated it
was not an easy place to get into and
that has changed a lot with that has
come the you know the hollowing out of a
lot of working-class white communities
and that has had a you know has had a
negative effect on them but it's meant
you know we've opened up a society we
are less racist but it's almost like
anti-racist don't really recognize that
anything's changed and you'll hear
people and there are academics people
like your Hindi Andrews or writers like
a for Hershel Reni ed Oh Lord who try
and argue that you know racism is still
there it's just more polite and you know
people's prejudices are hidden but
really they you know they don't want
your children's and you know they don't
want their children to marry someone
from a different ethnic background I
mean if you look at all the surveys
that's that's completely untrue racial
prejudices decline you know people are
for more accepting and willing to have
an ethnic minority boss or
a person marrying their son or daughter
from nothing honestly background you
know there is I would say that with with
Muslims and Islam there is more of a
prejudice and that is different that's
an outlier but in these other areas that
seems typical actually the thing that
hasn't gone down has probably gone up is
inter-ethnic tension which we never talk
about in this country you know the fact
that there is tension between Asians and
blacks in some parts of the country that
there's a lot of prejudice amongst those
groups both against whites but against
you know each other that that's you know
that's almost ignored because the
narrative we have now is white versus
black was the tension between some
African communities and Caribbean
communities and the fact they they some
they didn't get on they didn't like each
other it was a tension there and I've
never really been aware about that but
one thing I wanted to talk about because
the quickest way for me to start an
argument with anyone is mentioned the
two words white and privilege where do
you stand on it and it does it exists
first of all in your opinion and if so
how big a factor does it play in your
life in the UK I mean it's such an a
historic term it doesn't mean anything
really anymore I mean you could talk
about a white privilege in the context
of 1950s Alabama where being white had a
material impact on your life compared to
being black you know you had laws that
regulated where you could go what kind
of job you you know who you could marry
you know that kind of deep racial divide
then in that kind of context white
privilege makes absolute sense yeah why
privilege yeah it makes sense in that
context to an extent although you know
I'd say you know everything is more
complex but today it doesn't make sense
you know I think about you know I
mentioned my dad's friend I'm not quite
sure you know a white working-class guy
who works in a factory alongside Asian
people does he really have that much
more of a privilege
you know the people that the Asian
people that he's working alongside and I
don't think that it stands up as a
meaningful term well the Advanta the
example that people might give for a
white privilege where there might be
some credibility to is for example to
drive us doing the same thing on the
road right black people would argue a
black person is more likely to be pulled
over or something like that I mean the
whole stop and search thing is quite an
interesting discussion I've written
about it a bit the I mean the the
disparity between ethnic groups and the
white population in terms of how often
they get stops can it is largely
explained by what you know called
presence on the streets and whether
they're available to be stopped so how
many people rather than just looking at
the population at large numerically you
know how many people are in the
population how many black people is
proportionally you're looking instead at
how many people are in a particular area
on the street at night so younger people
tend to be disproportionately searched
men don't tend to be disproportionately
searched as well and there are at
amorites disparate it's particularly in
areas where there are high crime rates
so once you take all those factors into
account the disproportionality comes
right down so I think that argument that
well it's because they're black or it's
white privilege it's far too simplistic
yes there are as we said before there
are disparities and outcome but the
explanation behind it is is more complex
than well a white police officer just
sees a you know a black person driving a
car and stops them because they're black
and that's that's the kind of I think
that's a very crude discussion that
we're having now about police saying
though which is you know and then you
know that what that does is it means
that we are I think not policing well
enough we're not you know we're not
looking at crime particularly areas like
London and dealing with some of the
consequences of knife crime because
we're afraid of stop and search because
we're worried about you know the police
are worried about being regarded as
racist or politicians are
the impact of that is that we're not
doing proper policing and that has an
impact on the victims of crime who tend
to be disproportionately blood so if we
were having an honest conversation it
would be about whether you know whether
we need policing to be you know targeted
in areas of need and whether that means
that you know this disproportionality is
not the most important issue is it
effective policing and we could have an
interesting argument about how liberal
and libertarian we should be you know
when the police should stop what kind of
information they should have but too
often we don't have that honest
conversation because of this fear of
racial disparity and you think it's
almost the way we're talking about it's
just become a form of censorship hasn't
it really where people will have an
opinion an idea but they don't dare say
it because they're gonna get smeared and
doesn't that must create was it surely
an anger and bitterness doesn't does it
no yeah I mean that there was a there
was a very interesting report in the
Harvard Business Review about diversity
training in businesses and so the you
know the one the one way in which you
don't improve race relations and
business is you introduced diversity
because because white people feel very
very pissed off when they get told all
the time that they've got white
privilege and they have to be more
sensitive and it creates resentment and
but also it you know it just creates a
sense that you've got to treat people
differently and it just stops people
from thinking for themselves I think
that's that's the thing that has always
a grave ated me about the sort of anti
racism that it's essentially telling
people know your instincts your general
instinct to kind of treat everybody
equally in the same there's something
wrong with that and you have to think
carefully about before you speak it's a
form of policing which is not really in
the best interest of people it's it's
and it's also about shaming people you
know you're shamed into silence and even
where the statistics are clearly telling
a different story
everybody goes along with the narrative
that prevails you know and I've seen
it happens in the arts whole time where
we talk about you know unless there are
thirteen percent I think minorities
working in arts organizations you know
there's a you know there's systemic
racism II think we'll hang on that
thirteen percent it's probably based on
the proportion of BM you people in the
wider population but half of those
people proportionately are people who
were born in other countries so a large
number of them will you know will have
come from a very different background we
wouldn't expect them to necessarily be
running a theater you escape from the
poverty in Bangladesh to come here and
pursue an unpaid Korean comedy it's not
like some people will be you know
successful and you know but it's the
idea you just take a blanket figure and
that will tell you whether there's
systemic racism it's I mean it's crazy
but nobody will really challenge it and
you know most people have got day jobs
they're busy life's too short
I don't want to be the person in the
room that complains but I don't look
like the racist so I won't say anything
and I think my view is that the only
people really who can challenge this you
have a vested interest in challenging it
or ESIC minorities who see that it is
not in anyone's interest to perpetuate
this so I set up a blog actually which
I'd like to plug brilliant with some
friends called all in Britain all in
Britain org and we're a group of writers
from different ethnic backgrounds and we
write more critically about identity
politics basically and we try and show
that there are different ways of
thinking about these issues not every
black person has to take them in kind of
progressive anti-racist line there are
other types of anti racism there other
ways of being against racism which do
not have that kind of tinge of grievance
and that kind of reveling in victim
culture and and that's the you know I
think there needs to be a genuine
plurality a genuine diversity of views
amongst ethnic minorities and I think
you know everyone
lots of people in ethnic communities
feel that shamed of kind of speaking out
because they don't want to be seen as
dissing their own group or somehow not
being on the side of people in their
ethnic background and because you're
gonna get called volunteer
coconut whatever yeah people are afraid
of being you know and yeah we know
senior I think minority politicians a
you know court used the term Uncle Tom
yeah and you know you've seen this
happening with you know candidates like
Sean Bailey he was a conservative
candidates black and he's being attacked
because he dares to go outside you know
the the left-wing consensus and say well
I'm not going to find myself in that way
and not that's the sort of I think
that's just the very restrictive kind of
culture birthing minor she's facing it's
much more inhibiting than you know the
white oppression frankly in many ways
it's very interesting as especially seen
with the you know ethnic minorities when
they come out as being a conservative
it's a but they see it's almost seen as
a betrayal of their people and their
culture I was talking to a black
comedian and he was talking and he sort
of alluded to the fact that he wasn't in
left-wing and he wasn't on the Left but
when he told me we're in a green room
and he actually literally checked over
his shoulder and then started the
discussion because that's how
uncomfortable he felt about it
and you just think that you know this it
surely isn't that the antithesis of what
the left is about it surely something
miffed about being livable liberal about
being accepting of saying you know we
are different but we can come together
and we can have a society which works
and fashions it's not about pointing
fingers and demonizing people just
because they have a different idea
politically yeah I mean I yeah I um I
don't have a problem with people
disagreeing even you know disagreeing
very strident you know that's that's
what politics is and I fully expect you
know I've spent you know most of my
adult life
you know having you know a minority
opinion in a room you know and you know
particularly in the you know in the art
sets are kind of typical of what you see
is the sort of metropolitan liberal
elite I guess you know I'm very much
part of that that's my world those are
my friends and and yet you know we
disagree but you're right that the thing
that is you know I just I thought I you
know baffling is that people will talk
about wanting to be open-minded and
tolerant and welcomed diversity but
political diversity is the one thing
that they will not tolerate and
you know it's not if it means that you
never really challenged your own views
you never questioned and you know III
know why it's easier for people to live
in that way I know you know how hard it
is to go against the grain but I you
know I think society can't progress
unless we do have people you who's
saying well you know I think differently
about that really nicely onto the topic
that brings everybody together all
around the UK which is brexit well
before we get onto bricks I just wanted
to point out how skillfully you weaved
in a story by your one black friend real
he's real to me
but I mean breaks it now we have the
stereotypical image of the bricks or two
which is Lord yeah basically me in about
ten years
getting a bit more bitter and angry
slightly pink around the jail was waving
his finger talking about immigrants and
however you are a brick city yeah yep I
looks can be deceiving yes there are
some people like that yeah I'm not I
don't I don't think of myself as a
particularly angry person
i I but you know I've been you septic
for very long time I made my decision
you know after weighing up the pros and
cons you know I'm not some kind of you
know mad Zeller but I I just think we
are it's better to leave I would like to
have left in a better more orderly way
frankly it's not going you know as well
as one would hope but I still think in
the long term it's the right decision
because of the long term I you know for
the reasons I've said publicly in many
events that's spoken are you know I
think democracy and sovereignty are you
know parama in a society and you know
decisions that are made in a country
must be accountable to the people and
increasingly so many decisions are no
longer accountable people feel
disconnected from
decisions about the economy about law
about immigration and what's happened I
think since the vote which i think is
very interesting is how much
anti-democratic feeling there is and how
inhibited people are about expressing
that and I think that's extraordinary
you know and even you know interestingly
in the arts I've you know work something
out for a long time how as a sector we
really want to engaged I think it's
sincere we want to include people we
talk about bringing new people into
museums into theatres you know
discounting tickets reaching out and
then when the breaks it vote happened it
was almost like the light went off and
suddenly for a lot of people you know
those people are sick they're not
educated they rely - they didn't know
what they were voting for their opinions
their views no longer countered and I
don't think that's the case for all the
people who work in the arts think that a
lot of people in the middle like you
know many of us but unfortunately those
voices are very loud and very strident
and they appeared in the newspapers the
next day and it I think you know the one
thing this referendum has done is it
revealed that anti-democratic
Sensibility and I'm glad I'm glad it has
because I think we have to confront that
as a society and what that means and you
know and I'm you know I think it's
outrageous the way that you know people
were talking about you know
working-class people older people people
in the north as if they were subhuman no
it was almost like we were in the
Victorian era and we were saying
especially these people shouldn't be
allowed to vote because they didn't know
what they were voting for and we know
what's been in their best interest
because we have all the facts I thought
it's incredibly patronizing and you know
I'm glad that came out because you know
we have to see it for what it is and
Challenger it's amazing this act like
I've both of it Francis and I vote to
remain but because we're good people
[Laughter]
every time we break
so yeah the anti-democratic feeling
about it it's just like uh like I said
we both might remain and I was talking
to a comedian friend of mine and his
wife we were having dinner and I said
you know what if there's a second
referendum now I would vote to leave
because we had a vote and we have to
respect people as well otherwise you can
have you know you're gonna have trouble
on the streets otherwise in my opinion
right and they looked at me like I just
said the sacrificing baby yes is the
best government policy and Theresa may
should adopt it immediately and and I
just don't understand how these people
think is like you had a democratic vote
you lost and when that happens you
accept it and move on that's democracy
you don't accept the result of a vote
that's what we do in Russia what we do
in Ukraine are we doing as ever John or
whatever which countries which don't
have democracy so that it's amazing to
me that the people are in this position
now where it's like well who gives a
[ __ ] what the vote was we'll just do
what we want yeah yeah and also I mean I
was amazed that after the referendum
people who were not particularly
political or knowledgeable about the EU
suddenly developing this all-consuming
love for the EU and talking about it in
terms of you know it's you know the that
it was this kind of vehicle of peace and
prosperity and full employment across
the world you know it's almost like they
didn't even realize that you know Greece
and Italy as vania all these countries
are really suffering in the euro zone
and that it's been deeply
anti-democratic that it has I would
argue it's undermined workers rights in
many of these countries you know there
is a in this country they used to be
quite strong left-wing tradition against
the EU moon has ever seen as
anti-democratic this was a sort of Tony
Benn you know Jeremy Corbyn love you and
Britain is very unusual and it's
probably the only country in Europe that
doesn't have still a strong left-wing
opposition so that you and you know
my views on the EU you know most my
views are not kind of easily packaged
until left or right probably you know
I'd call myself a liberal but I have a
very strong view that you know people's
votes should count
and I would have thought that that was a
fairly natural obvious point for you
know most people somewhere in the middle
on the left and the right and I you know
it's amazing how many people think that
you know and and and believe that if you
have a second referendum that all that
other stuff will just go away the
people's views on that you you will just
dissipate they'll give up and then we'll
be back to normal and everything can
carry on you know the genies out of the
bottle you have to understand why people
voted that way and you know I I think
you know if were if people more
intellectually honest they would look at
it and say well you know maybe our world
view it does not encompass the full
range doesn't recognize that the EU has
not been an unalloyed good for everybody
in this country and one of the things
that I'm interested in in the research
doctrine about multiculturalism is the
importance of culture in creating
connections between people and the sense
of solidarity and I thought when people
talked about leave voters and people
outside London after the referendum you
could see that there was no sense of
solidarity with any of those people and
they would I remember having a
conversation with someone who's just
said well you know these people they
don't even work you know who what you
know he was angry because he thought you
know these are pensioners that you know
people who are unemployed who are you
know welfare and therefore they're not
my people and I it's depressing because
you know for countries to survive and to
be cohesive it needs to have a sense of
solidarity despite your differences and
and and you know maybe that's the you
know that's something you have to start
looking at you know how do we build that
sense that your interest what what
happens to you in your life you know if
you suffer that's my that's my
responsibility to and that I you know
that's where the welfare state came from
in a way is this idea that we're all
you're all women together you know you
have to look after each other a bit and
we can have disagreements within that
context but there has to be the kind of
basic recognition that you know these
people are our people we have to look
after them absolutely
it's been an absolutely brilliant
interview thank you so much for coming
on two questions before we let you know
one thing I just remembered we had to
Chloe Wesley on a couple of weeks ago
who said that we shouldn't have any
public funding of art because it's a
waste of money and I thought you might
be slightly triggered by that respond
well I respect Chloe very much that you
know she makes lots of good points and
but on this I disagree because I think
that you know there are times when the
state does fund institutions and it
funds things which the market is not
particularly good at funding you know I
don't believe that the market is always
the best arbiter of truth or judgment
and in the arts and in culture you know
what's popular is not always what's good
and we have to I think it's good to have
create other types of funding other
kinds of disinterested funding it's one
of the reasons why I do believe in a
publicly funded health system I mean we
could have a conversation about how the
NHS works and a degree of marketization
I like the mixed model because I think
it's there's a sound check and balance
about how funding works so in the arts
I'm you know and there are certain types
of institutions hurt certain types of
art which would just you know wither I
think without market from we if it was
just relying on the market for funding I
have a vested interest I'm on the board
of arts organisations so I you know you
could say that I'm conflicted but you
know it's not a huge amount of money but
it's about protecting something which is
important to a civilization as well
particularly in areas like heritage
where it's just expensive and it is
really hard to sustain some of our great
heritage assets through you know private
donations and ticket prices and you know
we we are responsible for you know
looking after our past as well as our
present so that's my answer on that
brilliant do wonder the last question
yes so the last question we always do
instead then the I did not everything
popular is good that's a Justin Bieber
argument that is the that's the way you
know everything is good but the way man
profound thinker
and the last question we always ask is
what is the thing that we're not talking
about society that we really should be
in your opinion um well this might sound
a bit left field but there is a reason
why when I was looking at stop and
search and I was looking at the
disproportionate number of BME men in
the prison system I was thinking a lot
about why that is and essentially I
think a lot of that has to do with the
drugs industry it is an industry in this
country it's an unregulated on policed
industry and drug legalization and I
don't have I haven't got a strident view
on either side about whether we should
have legalization or not but I think
it's one of those issues where
politicians are run a mile from it
because it's very very contentious they
think they'll lose votes and it's a very
difficult argument to have but I think
we need to have it is you know clearly
something is not working we have we have
criminal gangs in this country who
target vulnerable groups particularly
amongst the black community and a number
of those very young people are dying
they're being injured and it is because
they are you know they are foot soldiers
in a bigger war and I you know I think
the idea that you can just kind of and
you know and people take drugs
recreationally and they enjoy it and
that's not going to stop so something's
got to give and you know if policy
makers and politicians could look at it
honestly and rigorously we might have a
different conversation about it and that
I think would be a healthy thing so it's
a slightly left field know it was
brilliant we keep trying to get a few
people on to talk about drug
decriminalization I think it's really
important conversation with so many
different repercussions are used to
working um and the children that were
involved with ten and eleven years old
and they're big children who lived in
Newman and some of us when they turned
up in Aberdeen what they're doing
everything obviously there's runners and
it's tragic know I'm sitting
heartbreaking good note turn the show on
just a bit of tragedy clearances ELISA
mera thank you so much for coming here
you your blog just remind everybody
is all-embracing dog dog are you on
Twitter or the social media it's the
Twitter handle is just old in Britain
Britain perfect Facebook page and you
yourself do you have a Twitter account
yourself I don't I'm not on Twitter
Wow jealous well we are on social media
so as always follow us at trigger pod as
you will know by now we have a patreon
account as well at trigger pod as well
we've got a bunch of people already who
are subscribers on that so follow us on
that subscribe to us and we will see you
when we see you as you know season 1 of
trigonometry is now over this has been
the bonus episode for you as you've seen
we're on location with helicopters and
all the bells and whistles yep that you
can expect and fast is the last time
you'll see constant inside yes I've been
taken away and sure which will make
Francis incredibly happy so that's been
it we will be back very soon with a
bunch of other content for you we'll
keep you posted especially if you are
our patreon patron we will keep putting
out a little bits of information but
thank you very much for watching and
we'll see you very soon
you
[Music]
you